I actually want to pick up an idea well
this is a picking up an idea but I want
to pick up an idea that we looked at or
introduced yesterday which is that we
can think of the parabola not just as an
equation but as a series of
interconnected geometric items objects
right and there are few that are the
most important but really to will give
you everything else two features two
geometric objects that tell you
everything you need to know about any
parabola can someone tell you one of the
objects go ahead Rach okay the directrix
is a straight line and as the name
suggests it gives you the direction of
the parabola okay so we've got the
directrix and then what was the other
one the focus very good so the focus is
not a line the focus is a point around
which the parabola if you've got the
focus right here around which the
parabola kind of forms by the way if
you've ever seen like photos are big
that's a really terrible way of really
big satellite dishes like this right
yeah I failed you seven visual arts okay
leave me alone
if you've ever seen photographs of these
things or even if you have like a
satellite dish for like satellite TV or
something like that on your roof then
this thing here is the focus of a
parabola which is the dish in fact every
radar dish on the planet is a parabolic
dish in three dimensions every
cross-section no matter which way you
look is a parameter of some kind okay
we're going to explore a little more why
that is it's really quite ingenious but
we need to we're still laying
foundations okay so I just wanted to
point out that that's one of the
geometric properties of it yes you do I
mean well because you had to all right
and now we're going to teach you the
geometry of why it's quite it's quite
beautiful okay now from the directrix
and the focus you get everything else
you get the vertex you can find that you
get the lattice rectum that go across
all the other bits and pieces you can
find the equation itself if you know
what the
directrix and the focus are okay but
that means I can get other things in
relation to that for instance what we
did was we said directrix plus focus
equals or leads you to the equation of
the lockers right because what you did
was you said let's set a moving point P
and its distance to the focus is the
same as its difference from the
directrix okay so a quick note anytime
they say because you'll get this in the
textbook you'll get this in exams if
they say use the geometric definition of
the parabola or use the locus definition
of the parabola what they mean is you
need to come back to this it's a little
bit like with calculus you know how a
differentiation there's rules rules and
then there's first principles this is
first principles the rules are the
standard forms I introduced to you
yesterday you remember for right up down
left right so those are like the rules
you can just sort of quote them but this
is going back to the foundations okay
now therefore if this is true then you
can actually rearrange things a little
bit right for instance if from here you
can also get the vertex then that means
you can also if you have say the focus
and the vertex you can also get
everything else right these two pieces
of information are enough to infer
everything else for instance so this can
also feed you let's do this example
right now and I'm going to encourage you
to draw this and then try and work out
the geometry with me if I gave you the
focus as say let's call it the example
I'll give you is 3 comma 0
no sorry 0 comma 3 I mean it the other
way around
0 comma 3 and I told you that in
addition to the focus the vertex is
somewhere like say oh I don't know 0
comma negative 5 okay I want you to
think about what this means you may like
to refer back to
the images of the parabola that we've
drawn over the past few days to think
about how these two relate to each other
how can we actually work out everything
else from here any suggestions yes yeah
ah yep very good so from here to here
right away you know what the focal
length is right because it is the
distance between the focus and the
vertex what is it
the focal length it's gonna be eight so
this is out a right this is the value of
a when you have a look at it think about
this is this an up-down or a left-right
parabola which one is it how can you
tell it's up-down today what do you
think ah so what changes between these
two is just the y-coordinate and that's
up and down isn't it let's draw a
picture this is gonna be a lot easier
than me like waving around my fingers if
you enjoy yourself a picture here let's
position the focus and position the
vertex so zero comma three let's call
that yes yeah I haven't I haven't got
the directrix yet I will get it in a
second if I keep my scale consistent I
guess the vertex would be around here so
you can see again just picture the
satellite dish right the parabola has to
crowd around the focus so that tells you
this is not just an op down parabola
this is an OP parabola okay so you're
gonna get this kind of shape like so you
can work out the directrix now couldn't
you how do I find the directrix
okay very good you can that's one way of
saying it so if you go from here you
meant the focal length down and then you
go the focal length down again I guess a
simpler way to say it is it's one focal
length below the vertex okay so this is
eight and this is also eight so key
Tommy what the equation will be it'll be
y equals negative 13 we can draw it in
and of course we can also now that we
know what the focal length is and we
know it's a concave up parabola you can
also tell me the equation can't you it's
going to be x squared equals 4a which is
32 why there you go
and by the way x squared equals 32 why
would you describe that as a really
steep or a normal or really flat
parabola hmm now the 32 doesn't it's a
big number right but if you look
carefully one of the funny with one of
the unusual things about the UM the
locus form of the parabola is y is not
the subject so if we wrote it in like
sort of normal form I guess you would
write it like this y equals 1 on 32 x
squared which is actually very very flat
so this scale is really really wide so
when you have these things far apart you
have a very fat parabola okay um the
closer these guys come together the more
you shove things upward like that okay
all right
if you know the focus and the vertex you
can get there what if I gave you okay
let's try this now is example 2 what if
instead of giving you the directrix and
the focus I gave you the directrix and
the vertex okay so let's try this one on
for size how about a to think about it
vertex of and where's this gonna go x
equals 2 is that where I want it to be
ok so where's this going to be hmm this
requires some thought so I'll by the way
we've actually got a big problem with
with this I don't know if you noticed
that it looks good everything seems to
fit except
there's a big problem which kind of the
heading sort of leads you to what's the
x-intercept for this it should be the
origin shouldn't it in fact if you look
back at the four versions of the
standard forms they gave you every
single one passes through the origin did
you notice that so this is like your
nice neat you know convenient standard
forms but they're not always so so I'm
gonna need to adjust this in a minute
I'll come back to this in a second okay
just think about this with me first draw
a picture
get yourself a Cartesian plane where is
everything positioned x equals two
that's a what kind of line it's vertical
right it's on the right over here x
equals two like so and then you've got
your vertex over here at if that's two
one two three there you go
there's my vertex okay so what can you
tell me about this now which way is it
going it's concave left very good
because you can see it's going to face
away from the directrix and it's going
to have to pass through here so it's
going to look something like this that's
the direction it's facing can you tell
me where the focus is going to be it's
gonna be well the distance here the
focal length is going to be five and we
know that this distance is the same as
this five is gonna be the same over here
so therefore you can now tell me the
coordinates of the focus are negative 8
comma zero right so let's put that guy
in
okay now if this passed through the
origin if it passed through the origin
which form would we use you've got four
standard forms to choose from which one
would you use let me give you a clue it
will not begin with an x squared it's
gonna begin with a y squared because
left right okay that's the first thing I
know it it's facing to the left which
direction is that 4x it's the negative
direction so therefore we negative now
the for a the for a would be 21 turn and
then normally I would have an X but
we've noted that our standard forms
aren't coping with this well because
neither of these pass through the origin
so these equations while close can't
match up so how do I reposition this
I've got the focal length right I've got
the the facing direction like up and
down the left and right I've got those
correct so how do I translate how do I
shift around a parabola suggestions
addition and subtraction are going to be
the operations I'm going to use but the
question of course is where and what I'm
gonna do some addition and subtraction
let's come back to this guy for a minute
where am I going to do it mmm Eric what
do you reckon from here
wait all in five minus five like that is
that what you're suggesting what do you
guys think is that going to do it let's
just quickly test it we can look at
coordinates and see what happens when x
equals zero do we get the Y value that
we wanted looks okay to me because if
you think about this you're going to get
zero here just poof disappears so you
get negative five which is what I was
after
now this is awkward though this is not
in the form that I was using it before
so how am I going to fit it back into
the form we were using earlier do I just
do I just do I add five do I subtract
five how can I fit it so it looks more
like this rather than this way which
doesn't have anything to do with the
lockers definition what would you like
me to put in where let me give you a
suggestion before I come to this right
this minus five we're thinking about it
as where where lower so you subtracted 5
which does actually give you the right
value however it's totally in the wrong
place because look it seems to be
mucking around with this X X's aren't up
and downs where should this 5 really be
ha now we're talking okay so of course
it has to be in brackets has to be in
brackets because this entire thing has
been divided by 32 to get to this line
but now if you try out x equals what I
say x equals 0 x equals 0 do you see
then the 32 will divide through it'll
cancel giving you zero equals y plus 5
which is what you wanted
okay so this is what I'm after this is
better how about over here I've moved
which way am I going to the left on left
of the origin and I'm left by three
units yeah so therefore what shall I do
in here
because remember when you're translating
the turn that you add in here you just
check it out like put in y equals zero
and you want this to become zero so
therefore negative three is the answer
that gets you that okay